alors vous vous étiez non alors à peu
près à peu près comment tourner et vous
savez c'est seydou chinois sur tf1 par
mois je sais pas on attend les 150000
euros
quoi par 150 moi moi c'est à moi j'avais
j'avais dit aux gars que j'avais la une
est à vous non j'avais plein de spécial
et spéciales soit il fait chaud ici et
je me demande je vais me poser vous
montiez 150 mille francs qui sont sa
copine aux 750 millions d'euros et il a
cité la sienne franc on est en france et
en france oui mais là il a converti
seulement après vous souvenez quand même
que la une est à vous c'était le rendez
vous un peu du mouvement dimanche et
michel rmr a été le rendez vous
incontournable des marques aux déchets
ne vous a pas demandé de défendre son
salaire n'ont pas de salaire mais parce
que la vraie info non mais elles vous
touchent et 150000 euros par mois ce
qu'il faut dans ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est maintenant mais ce qu'il faut
savoir
[Rires]
là je reçois des tweets de partout ça a
duré une décennie ben brik one à la
décennie à s'en [ __ ] plein les poches
on lui a proposé c'est qu'en fait à
l'époque il y avait un vous rappelez pas
mais avant le jt même de 20 heures pour
le stimuler
il y avait des séquences de vidéo gag
donc on a beaucoup tourné là dessus
c'était devenu une quotidienne plus tous
les week-end le samedi et le dimanche
ah ouais t il en a chié le montueux mais
s'était fait gentiment tcc du 6 millions
il a fait tellement de lancement
quarantaine
j'avais j'avais j'avais trois quatre
émissions qu'il avait fait tout très
bien mais c'est vrai sur les fêtes avec
un empire je suis sous l'effet des